it's torture
it's i'm in so much pain lies build upon
lies and build upon lies i'm obsessed
with the truth
courtroom drama delivers some of tv's
highest ratings
so this dark reality a hollywood
scriptwriter's dream
sordid star-studded saddening
at the heart of this bruising seven-week
court battle the dispute over the truth
contradicting claims of domestic abuse
[Music]
he just hit me over and over and over
again and i got really still
i thought this is how i die never
did i myself
reach the point of the striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
in my life
and for every allegation made another
entirely contradicting version of events
miss in her frustration and in her rage
and her anger she would uh
strike out she would
it could begin with a slap it could
begin with a
shove
this messy legal battle the antithesis
of the cool celebrity power couple they
once channeled
meeting on set of the rum diary in 2009
marrying in 2015.
when i was around johnny i felt like the
most beautiful person in the world
you know made me feel seen made me feel
like a million dollars she was too good
to be true she was
attentive she was
but just over a year after their wedding
heard took out a restraining order
against depp do you know whether or not
you took this picture
and six years after their divorce the
ruins of their relationship picked over
in this courtroom and televised to the
world
he with these statements with these
these these leaks these comments
once again
makes me
have to speak to the most horrifying
things i've looked through
[Music]
you'd be forgiven for a sense of deja vu
as in the summer of 2020 disturbing
evidence of johnny depp and amber
heard's violent and messy marriage was
poured over at the high court as johnny
depp took on the sun and lost but
undeterred by the high court ruling depp
pressed on with the sequel
depp determined to clear his name over
this opinion piece in the washington
post in which ms heard described herself
as a survivor of sexual violence she
didn't name johnny depp but he says it's
plainly about him and is suing for 50
million damages i didn't
deserve that nor did my
children nor did the people who have
believed in me for
all these years at the time of the uk
court case depp had been filming
fantastic beasts three in london but he
would be replaced by mads mickelson
filmmakers want to think and say you
know who do we want to hire in our
movies and is this the sort of character
is this the sort of person that we
actually want to associate ourselves
with and work with
[Music]
and there lies the crux of this libel
case depp's loss of earnings
his former agent christian carrino said
after playing jack sparrow in five of
the pirates of the caribbean films he
missed out on the sixth because of the
allegations his current agent testifying
it had been catastrophic to his career
what opportunities has mr depp had since
july 2020
he has not
done a film
but the costs escalate beyond employment
issues it has been an unedifying
portrait of a volatile relationship
johnny had already grabbed amber by the
hair with one hand and was whacking her
repeatedly in the face with the other
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs she then
grabbed that bottle
and uh
and through that at me
i honestly didn't i didn't feel the pain
at first at all i felt no pain
whatsoever
the tip of my finger
had been severed
but miss heard's version of events that
night in australia are entirely
different a graphic description of
sexual violence
i'm on the countertop
it had me by the neck
and he felt like he was on top of me and
i'm look i'm looking at it in his eyes
and i don't see him anymore
i've never been
so scared of my life
[Music]
[Applause]
the evidence has been shocking but the
force of this case has impacted way
beyond this courtroom the unique nature
of johnny depp's fan base securing huge
influence depp's lawyers are using
tremendous amount of resource
to get a message across that she's a
broken woman she's unstable she's a
psychopath she's untrustworthy
amber heard is a psychopath
hashtag amber heard
is a liar there is no doubt that this
trial has left johnny depp's brand
entirely radioactive i just don't think
that johnny depp has a future in
hollywood anymore i think hollywood
definitely has a great capacity for
forgiveness when it comes to certain
types of celebrities
whether or not depp or heard will find
retribution this case leaves a legacy of
regret
i love this man so much
and it was
so toxic
it's very
strange when
one day your
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds your quasimodo
[Music]